Deo need a rider from a sharp angle and the Jets
on their toes early Marcy on the Move here's Lowry
with the drive and that stopped terasa can't
cover Lowry that shot a big crowd in front it
hits somebody almost W nothing and the jackets
clear it leaving it Bist cing pass good stick
there by fany to break it up and here come the
jets elers turning it on weaving now to his left
Brendon Dylan out front of the net oh you let
it go and he scored Brendon Dylan one winipeg
they litigate damage so once coming their way
I block shot and then look at the way that all
five guys start heading northward I love the delay
on entry from eers so instead of him driving the
middle of the Icees to two wide guys one being
a d man Brendan Dylan little backhand favor over
to number five who lobs this one so that one
off the Stick of G Branson you could see that
Dyan was trying to center it and Brendon Dillan
ties his career high in goals with six that pass
to the slot there's a shot kicked Away by heluk
things are pretty open here Jets D are so good
that shooting for sticks right there it's exactly
what pan did to low stick a little tip low set it
up Le runer with a quick shot look at that tic
tac toe and it's left there by sson he'll get
it back in the corner D sson gave it away to W
follow he put it off the back of the net here's
domestic off but it bounced away from him Aro on
the back check attention on elers there isn't it
and that's this team knows how dangerous he's
been here comes Marko shoots it blocker save
off the shot up ahead is shley valard staying in
shape himself and he's one of those guys that kind
of lead by example lives this life the right way
and I he's a fantastic young coach for a young
team he came in under difficult circumstances as
that shot hit the post from Cinder this game off
The Rush look at that go cross grain and one went
off the post right there off of the glove of hel
off of the post there's another look at it wow CR
LS that toward the line it went past SMI a little
bit ragged here the last minute or so the Branson
head man it intercepted by culer Fetti quick shot
by aalo and the glove save by tasa claimed by sber
behind the nette shley hangs on with Bess car to
away whacking at him what a pass for Appleton
Sublime set up by shley this Saturday to come
well that wouldn't make them Ries would it uh
I don't think so there's a shot loose in front
of the goal and collected there by Janson fi
he'll skate away with itus had a good chance
earlier as Cinder hit the post and cross bar all
in one Fell Swoop when you get home at 4:00 a.m.
that makes you a ro though doesn't it buddy I
think so he got some rest today uh not really
Blue Jackets off the rush that shot by baronov
Jack roslovic just his 20th game of the season
prer off the front of the kicking at it sto by
huk as he took it right to the front of the goal
now floated in by baronov at the deal with an
oncoming Olivier he's a a physical player he's
got the puck behind the goal Olivier turns in the
forehand he got it to the front of the net but
texier could not put that one in for proov Left
for Cole sinder shot by serson blocked there by I
notched ahead for naskov proov get back in a hurry
to support serson short angle shot knocked Away by
tasa valard tried to strip the puck he almost
did judg did J's had a strong start to this one
bean buled that away that hit the referee skate
now shely in front trying to settle it with the
shot away and teras off snags that one with the
glove dump that isn't played very well from teras
off that bues enough time lardi with the check on
good Bron look at the support tight and quick from
shley now you win a battle when you reload again
bardi comes to help out a secondary chance from
eers and a shot in tight from sh I I mentioned it
earlier if you want to check the buyin level from
a team the Jets pushing for goal two per Fetti the
mov gets on the Move he'll flip it over flag down
by Schmidt Dylan Samberg Cuts behind the goal up
front Peretti scores [Music] [Applause] [Music]
goals and three straight for Cole Peretti off a
beautiful pass from Samberg and it's two nothing
WI a p it's Dylan Samberg now with points in his
last three look at the way he waits scans a little
5 foot pass to a one touch eight goals 18 points
for SE for the midle he bags that out of the Zone
take any chances there Here Comes Lowry they keep
it on side Lowry for morsy fire [Music] scores
and what a reaction from Mory after a rocket
makes it three nothing [Applause] Jets into this
one how about the def factoring into the scoring
tonight Brendan Dylan started it off Samberg with
a beautiful pass to Peretti and then how about
this one a nice little pass from Lowry and Josh
morsey has the wide Lane to skate downhill and he
releases the down to the top [Applause] Corner wus
took the pass from terason Al G gets the trio of
Jets appeton trying to cut things up and he does
and he's got the best the C with him Mason appeton
coming back quickly Johnson appeton the forand oh
a nice blade draws a penalty power play I thought
was average at best from clus because they Bobble
little pu in right there that's full control of a
puck that you just give up for free good Appleton
will take it so he goes the other way and pulls
onto it drives to the net and has an opportunity
to score but evens things out here draws another
Power Play for his team to boot save by H might
have hit the side of the net H he missed it anyway
he was taking no Cates Mory Under Pressure turned
it over rosic back door pass what a stop by H he
got the left hand on it to n Tei forcement help
there it is he comes back there's texier and how
about that wraps his toe of his stick around that
a give and go and then to the back door great
shot from Tex even better save how about this
from huk respect the shot and then to the was
locked away by Dan for but picked off at Center
by the mes the off right back for ialo trying
to get loose and get on it for fetty spin move
and what a maneuver it was following up by aalo
it's chipped away though by serson winipeg wins
so many Puck battles in this last bit and they
win another one and it's Peretti who [Applause]
scores Cole Peretti his second of the game and
it's four nothing Winnipeg line for the Jets
just Blitz the D there's just nowhere to go with
it two layers of offense two layers of Defense we
don't have it and now we do nice job coming from
above from Nikolai eers eyo protects it loses it
and then there's that second layer Peretti skates
downhill into that a quick stick recovers it and a
quick release four goals in his last three games
and he beats dead for f jets with possession to
start the power play heers to the corner help
get the Jets off to a good start setting up
Dylan for the game's first goal Adam Lowry out
front here's a chance at valard converts he
scored J pouring it on now on the power play third
attempt really nice play attack the net from Lowry
so he forces ter off to squeeze the strong side
post respect the shot nope there's the pass hubard
kicks it up to his stick and just as quickly
in the back of the net to nitpick is a good
thing particularly when you're having success to
settle is not a good thing when you're at the top
how you stay there is to look for other areas you
can improve and heluk kept it out of the redirect
cter heluk with his side to the shooter makes the
save but he has made a couple spectacular saves
this being one of them not an easy thing to do
when the other team isn't pushing their case very
much that one changes Direction big time to the
slot a p a slap pass and hellu reacts perfectly
the Jets with points at 13 Stak and there's
seven straight Victory and hellu makes the late
save he's got the shut out they beat the blue
jacket 5 nothing and are in first place in the
NHL